المترجم: Bassel Almehman
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
هل صوتي مسموع؟
أنا كنت أحلى واحدة وأذكى واحدة وأهم واحدة.
كانت كل طلباتي مجابة تقريبًا.
حتى ولِد طفل صغير أخذ مني كل شيء.
أحسست بهذا الإحساس مرتين.
المرة الأولى: عندما ولدت أختي الصغيرة
وأنا عمري ثلاث سنين. أهلًا ندى.
والمرة الثانية: عندما أصبحت أمًّا
وأنا عمري 23 سنة.
في المرة الأولى كانت المشاعر مبررة.
كان الإحساس في مكانه.
الغضب مفهوم.
يجلبون لك هدية في المستشفى من الطفل.
يعطونك وقت أكثر مع الكبار.
لكن في المرة الثانية كان شعورًا غريبًا.
غير منطقي، ليس في مكانه.
كان إحساسًا محرجًا جدًّا.
كيف أنا أم لأول مرة، صحتي جيدة وولدي بخير.
لماذا لدي هذا الإحساس؟
كان شعور جدًّا محرج ومخزي،
وكان سر كبير لم أعترف به حتى لنفسي.
كثير من المشاعر التي نشعر بها في أيامنا
ليست بالضرورة وليدة اللحظة.
تعدي فترة الطفولة والمراهقة بتجارب وخبرات
تكون مشاعرها جدًّا قوية ولم نتعامل معها.
فتصبح كأنها نظارة ترى الحياة من خلالها.
والذي يحدث معنا شيء اسمه التحوّل.
أول من تكلم عن هذا المبدأ
العالم النمساوي فرويد.
أو بالعربية، نقل شعور أحسسنا
به في الماضي إلى اللحظة، الآن.
مثال: موظف محترم راقي سعيد في عمله،
في اجتماع مديره قال له
تعليق بسيط على أدائه.
فجأة هذا التعليق في لحظة يذكره بشيء
كان يقوله له والده وهو طفل.
يحس بمشاعر غضب،
يحس بمشاعر أكبر من الموقف بكثير.
ويقوم بتصرف يخرج فيه عن طوره.
شعور مألوف، صحيح؟
بعدها يقول: "لم أكن نفسي.
لا أعرف لمَ فعلت هكذا."
ويدخل في حالة من كره الذات.
من الممكن موقف صغير مثل هذا يفقده عمله،
أو ممكن أن يقضي أسبوع محرجًا منه بعدها.
لكن الذي يحدث معنا أننا نعيش
بفكرة أن ما ذهب فقد ذهب.
لا ننتبه للأشياء التي تحدث في حياتنا اليوم
ويمكن هي كمحرك دمى يحركنا
ويجعلنا نقوم بالتصرفات التي نقول عنها
لا أعلم لمَ فعلت هكذا،
أو لا أعلم لمَ خرجت عن طوري،
أو لا أطيق نفسي.
من أنا ومن نفسي؟
فأنا بالنسبة لي في تجربتي توجد علامتين
للشيء تدلني أن هذه التجربة مرتبطة بالماضي.
أولا، يكون الإحساس مبالغ فيه جدًّا.
ثانيا، تكون ردة الفعل أكبر من الموقف
ولا يقبلها المنطق.
فالنتيجة غالبًا محرجة.
في رحلتي القصيرة للتصالح مع نفسي،
استوعبت أني لن أستطيع أخذ
أي خطوة للأمام دون أن أتصالح مع نوف
التي عمرها 16 سنة وآخذها بيد،
وأتصالح مع نوف التي عمرها أربعة سنين
وآخذها باليد الثانية.
وحدة من تجاربي للتصالح مع الماضي
كانت أن كتبت رسالة لنوف التي عمرها 16 سنة.
"عزيزتي نوف، أعرف أنه غريب
أنك تقرئين رسالتي لكن ابقي معي.
أريد أن أقول لك بعض الأشياء.
أريد أن أقول لك أنك جميلة.
لا وزنك ليس زائد،
ولا تحتاجين لأي عملية تجميل
أنفك جيّد.
أريد أن أقول لك أن عيونك
فيها كواكب ونجوم.
أن ابتسامتك ملائكية.
وأن قلبك على الرغم من همومه
يحمل نور الدنيا كلها.
أعرف أن الأيام بطيئة،
أعرف أنك لا تشعرين بالأمان،
وأعرف أنك ما زلت تخافين من الظلام.
أعرف أنك تعلّمت سماع كلامك
وأن تكوني مجتهدة.
تعملت قول نعم حتى تكوني رضيّة.
أعرف أنك تحاولين إرضاء أهلك، وتفشلين.
أعرف أنك تحاولين
تكوين صداقات في المدرسة، وتفشلين.
أعرف أنك متمسكة بشدة بفكرة وجود رب،
وتحاولين أن يكون هذا الرب راضٍ عنك،
وتفشلين.
أعرف أن الفشل ليس خيار بالنسبة لك،
لكن ما زلتي تفشلين.
دعيني أقول لك بعض الأشياء.
الكبار وإن كانت نيتهم حسنة،
لا يعلمون دائمًا ما يفعلونه.
في كثير من الأحيان يجربون أشياء مختلفة
حتى يروا ما الذي يصلح منها.
حتى تشعري بهم، اسأليهم عن طفولتهم،
اسأليهم عن مراهقتهم، عن أيامهم الصعبة.
لأن الشخص الذي يجرح غيره،
غالبًا يكون هو مجروح.
لا لستِ مدلعة، حدسك العالي
وحساسيتك المفرطة التي دائمًا يسخرون منها
هي طاقاتك الخارقة.
نوف، رحمك هو رحم الكون،
هو محط النفخة الإلهية.
منه تُولد بنات أفكارك،
وفيه تُخلق ألف حياة وحياة.
عادتك الشهرية التي تحرجين منها
متصلة بمنازل القمر.
أريد أن أؤكد لكِ أن احتياجاتك حقيقية.
أن خيالاتك حالمة.
أن روحك طاهرة.
لا تدعي أحدًا يقول لك غير هذا.
العطاء الزائد على حساب نفسك
لن يجعلك أبدًا تحصلين على الحب.
فقط عندما تحبين نفسك وترضين عنها
سيناديكي الحب.
من الطبيعي أن تستلطفي شخصًا.
سأقول ذلك، شيء طبيعي.
ستتعلمين مع الوقت الفرق
بين الصداقة والحب والإعجاب.
نوف، الزواج قد يكون بداية جديدة،
لكن ليس بالضرورة يكون نهاية سعيدة.
أفلام الكرتون، القصص الخيالية، الأفلام
التي كبرنا عليها ينتهي الفيلم بزواج شخصين،
ليست دائمًا نهاية، هذه بداية.
إذا نظرتِ في المرآة ستعلمين
أنك أنتِ الفارس الملثّم الذي تنتظرينه.
لن تتزوجي أول شخص تحبينه،
والذي تتزوجيه ليس شرطًا
أن يكون آخر شخص تحبينه.
أريد أن أقول لك أن لهجتك لطيفة.
دائمًا ستكونين مختلفة في محيطك،
ولن تنسجمي بالضرورة مع كل الناس.
لأنك عندما تكونين حقيقية،
سوف تجدين من يشبهونك.
استشيري عقلك لكن حكّمي قلبك، هو دليلك.
أخيرًا، أريد أن أقول لكِ
أن جسمك هو واديكِ المقدس.
في هذا المكان أنا وأنتِ نتقابل،
وفي هذا المكان القطرة تلاقي المحيط،
والمحيط يلاقي القطرة.
ومن هذا المكان تكونين أنتِ والحياة واحد.
نوف، أنتِ مهمّة، وحياتك مهمّة،
وقصتك ملهمة لي، وربما لغيري."
شكرًا.